so obviously season one i feel like it's
fair to say you guys had some success i
mean you got an emmy out of it
uh how nervous were you about heading in
were there nerves about heading into
season two
well yes of course uh the uh
i'm old enough to know that success in
this industry is
rare and fleeting and
the the last thing you want to do is uh
rub the shine off something that has
been a blessing to be a part of
that being said
you also get
as you get older wise enough to know
that really all you have is the process
and
when you are collaborating with people
that inspire you and enlighten you and
pressure you and
destabilize you so that you have to be a
better version of yourself it's the
greatest possible working environment
you could be in and i knew that going
into season two two i would i would be
surrounded by the same kind of um uh
ambition and thrill and creativity and
uh passion
um in all the people that that were in
in addition to some of the new cast
members that we um welcomed into it so
it wasn't uh
my my enthusiasm and my excitement
far surpassed any kind of uh nervousness
that's awesome um obviously you talked
about you know working with this
incredible cast i mean in particular i
feel like i have to highlight your uh
working relationship with reese i mean
it's very dynamic it's very fun to watch
what do you enjoy most about having her
as a scene partner
well we're both approaching the scenes
in in the same way which is the
characters are trending lightly around
each other there's some kind of shared
dialogue there's some kind of shared
agenda
there's some kind of shared affection
but they haven't really put their hands
on or articulated it to one another
clearly so there's always a bit of a
guessing game and
uh confusion with putting yourself too
far out there and
solidifying what certainly corey feels
is a pretty strong
ideological and emotional bond uh but
the he's not the kind of character that
easily
uh expresses that so
i i think the same goes for bradley in a
way that
despite her being
so capable
at expressing her point of view and her
needs in some
environments i think when questioned
um or confronted with something
unexpected
she takes the same position corey does
which is utter confusion and
when together the two of us can be
flabbergasted uh it i i i confess it's
really fun to play yeah uh lastly uh
last question is obviously you know a
large part of the season focuses on the
beginning of 2020 which we all lived
through was it sort of surreal to
experience some of that i forgot some of
the stuff that even happened
yeah no question about it i remember the
scene that i did with greta where they
put up a plexiglas uh sort of
enclosure around my desk and
the two of us we honestly didn't know
how to respond because
there was a part of it that was so
absurd
that
it seemed like so many things had
happened since then to give us
information about that particular kind
of
behavior or help um but the the struggle
to understand how to
navigate that environment was
um
it was
hard to re-encounter as something new
because we have been spending every hour
of every day doing it since then so
there was a really odd quality to
figuring out how to play that it's
probably some of the best acting is just
us dismantling all of the things that
were weighing over us all the time
yeah well thank you so much for chatting
with me and congrats in season two thank
you so much i appreciate it